our entire team is tracking all these
developments for you hector mejia
and david charns are following the
lawsuit being filed by the trump
campaign
but first to bianca holman she's live at
the clark county election headquarters
with more on today's update hi bianca
clark county registrar joel gloria he
actually says that his department is
focused on
accuracy not quickness when it comes to
the counting of
these votes and matter of fact his
elections department right now
they are working on counting continuing
to count ballots they're actually going
to plan to count
51 000 ballots today now that number
includes valid
dropped off on election day ballots
received in the mail and ballots that
were pending so far
here's the latest numbers the registrar
shared on election day there were just
over 34 000 ballots submitted in the
drop boxes
the u.s postal service has delivered 4
208 ballots
the elections department and there were
two
three 24 eleven ballots that were
pending when they stopped counting
ballots to get ready for election day
that brings us to a total of sixty three
thousand two hundred and sixty two
there are more ballots that are pending
outside of what i just shared such as
provisional ballots or ballots that have
not been received yet
by in the mail regardless of the number
all ballots will be counted
okay we're not concerned with breeding
as fast as we can
we're concerned with making sure that
we're accurate and what we report
because this is a very important
election in the state of nevada it may
make the decision for the president
so we take that very seriously and we
will make sure
that we're doing everything properly
since mail-in ballots are continuing to
become come in
there will be updates on saturday and
sunday
and there will be another update from
the registrar regarding the
voting and regarding the accounting of
the ballots tomorrow
on friday at 10 a.m we of course will be
having it live on air
and online reporting here in north las
vegas bianca holman
8 news now